hello so this is the other side of the
story you don't have to look at your
data let the algorithms do it I know
it'll be complementary I think to what
we just saw I'm a data scientist and
NextEra Energy up in Juno Beach but this
is totally unrelated to me that so in
fact this isn't even my own work so I
want to make it very clear to begin with
that I stole everything and I want to
give most of the gratitude to the auto
ml group at University of Freiburg in
Germany where these top three authors
wrote the main paper I'll be
highlighting and I think these bottom
two guys work together on the first
chapter of this book that I'm stealing a
lot of stuff from too but they're all in
the same research group so what is hyper
parameter optimization let's just be
clear about that before we get going on
how to do it
so most ml algorithms have something
that needs to be specified before you
can actually feed it data and let us
start learning right so these things
that have to be specified up front are
hyper parameters and even if you aren't
specifying them they're usually there
there's maybe set to default right so
using an algorithm to choose those type
of parameters is then hyper parameter
optimization or hpo just to kind of put
this into context there's something kind
of more inclusive called Auto ml where
you would then be automatically
searching through what algorithm to use
pre-processing feature engineering
feature selection tuning the hyper
parameters maybe ensemble Araya T of
these models and it's kind of like
automated data science in general right
and so I'm just going to be focusing on
hyper parameter optimization and leave
the rest of that out it's kind of
debatable on if you want to include
pre-processing as a hyper parameter or
not so if you have a neural network
maybe whether or not you do CCA on the
images before you feed them into the
algorithm could be a boolean hyper
parameter
or something but up so why HPL I think
the most obvious answer is if you choose
good hyper parameters you'll get better
model performance right so that's kind
of a no-brainer default settings will
usually give some sort of result but
they're really not your friend okay and
they won't get their feelings hurt if
you decide to change them and no there
is not one learning rate to rule them
all although everyone has their favor to
start with right but I think kind of a
more overlooked reason to do HP oh-- is
the second one that if you're trying to
make valid comparisons between different
models for the same data set it's
totally unfair and invalid to compare
the algorithms unless you spend equal
amount of effort or computational
resources tuning the hyper parameters
right so it wouldn't be uncommon to say
oh I've got this great new algorithm it
works so great I tuned the crap out of
it on this data set giving me excellent
and look it beats that that and that
because I left them on their default
settings right so I think it's really
important especially if you're doing
research to use hyper parameter
optimization to make fair comparisons
okay
many people manually tune hyper
parameters I know I've been there but
would you ever manually tune your
regression coefficients and just looking
at the validation score until you think
you found the best coefficients for your
regression model right even if you're
really good at it like oh I've been
doing this a long time I'm really good
at it
no right that sounds crazy when you put
it like that I'd also like to highlight
something called variable ratio variable
ratio reinforcement schedules this is
what casinos used to get you do addicted
slot machines right if the reward might
or might not happen on the next pull and
you go kind of long droughts in between
polls that offer your reward in this
case finding hyper parameters that work
the best so far
it's an excellent way to make you keep
pulling that lever right so I don't know
about you but you know you've got your
data site pre-processed all ready to go
pick your favorite algorithm start with
a set of hyper parameters let it run
wash the validation
scores go by especially if it only takes
a minute or two right and I say oh I'll
tweak it this way and do it again tweak
it this way oh it's got better do it
again
oh he got better do it again right it's
before you know it and our two's gone by
and you've just out there manually
tuning in grad school we used to refer
to graduate student descent when you
just have a professor till the grad
student go tune the algorithm form but
we're doing data science here so if
we're trying to tune something we should
use an algorithm right so take the time
to learn a good open source library for
a hyper parameter optimization and never
go back to the casino okay really the
biggest barrier is that finding a good
open source library in the past has been
non-trivial or one that has continuous
support there's been somewhere owned for
a long time but they kind of stopped
being maintained or whatnot so I like
one at the end of this talk here so a
formal kind of problem formulation here
hpo is a hard problem because we're
essentially optimizing a black box where
the domain is our hyper parameter
configuration space our range is a real
number which we would want to make it be
like our models generalizability or test
set performance so we're mapping from
hyper parameters to test that
performance the only problem is this
black box function is very expensive to
evaluate because to evaluate it we have
to train a model right so some deep
learning models this could be hours or
days
I think Google's BIRT model to something
like a year's worth of v100 time to
train so the other problem is that it's
a noisy function evaluation so remember
we're trying to get the best test set
performance and we can only approximate
that with validation set performance and
that's noisy right because you get a
different validation set you'll get a
different score and it's you know some
unbiased estimator of the test set
performance in theory right another
thing that's hard about it is in general
you can't back prop through training a
model although there was one paper I saw
that did manage to approximate that
somehow the
pretty cool button generally have no
gradient information in this
optimization right so what makes a good
hpo algorithm so first off it has to be
flexible enough to accommodate your
hyper parameter space so you will have
some real valued hyper parameters some
integers some categorical variables
conditional variables for instance
whether or not to add a second layer to
your net or whether or not to add that
third layer and then once you add those
layers you have to choose how big they
are so choosing the size of your third
layer is only relevant if you have a
third layer or whether or not you're
going to use regularization then what is
the regularization coefficient you're
going to use and so on and then also
it's got to accommodate high dimensional
spaces right because in a lot of these
more complicated models are getting a
lot of hyper parameters now I've got
these two terms kind of sound the same
but I'm gonna use them to mean different
things so efficient means that each step
of the algorithm has to be computable in
a reasonable amount of time whereas
effective means that it takes a fairly
small number of steps to get a good
answer
scalable I really mean scaling out or
running parallel robust this one's this
one's really important and tricky
because it sneaks in if were you going
to use an algorithm to perform an
optimization that algorithm might have
some hyper parameters and you don't want
hyper hyper parameters because it's
sometimes at some point the buck stops
with you and you've got to set it right
so robust would mean you want an
algorithm that works pretty bunch out of
the box the default parameters on any
problem okay and that eventually it will
find a good solution even if you didn't
set those hyper hyper parameters to a
good value and then easy I think has
probably been the barrier that why
everyone is still doing men or not
everyone why most people still go to
manually tune their hyper parameters
it's because it's not easy to write
these things from scratch all by
yourself there's a lot of moving parts
right so really that comes down to
finding something that's already
existing and well-maintained and easy to
use getting familiar with it
and then you don't want your algorithm
to eat or sleep right seriously stop
going to the casino right so the first
class of algorithms I'll talk about is
model free methods so here you're
searching over your domain which
remember is your hyper parameter
configuration space without ever really
trying to model the mapping from that
domain to your range of test performance
so you're searching and getting a value
you use that value to inform your search
somewhat but you're not actually trying
to create a model that approximates that
function right so the most basic one
would be grid search where you lay a
grid over your configuration space and
check every point don't do that
a minimum go to random search there's
lots of good theoretical reasons for
this grid search you end up repeating
the same parameter setting a whole bunch
of times and you'd be better off to
injecting some random noise around that
so random search is almost or it is
always better than grid search don't use
grid search
there's heuristic search methods like
ant colony optimization and particle
swarm optimization the problem with
these methods is they in general need a
lot of function evaluations which isn't
great when they're very expensive right
and there's evolutionary algorithms and
genetic programming again it can take a
lot of function evaluations
I know these are quite popular when you
get up to the whole auto ml scheme
though for like feature engineering for
instance where you will take different
features and combine them in crazy
different ways through genetic
programming last class here is
multi-resolution algorithms the idea
here is that instead of doing this
really expensive evaluation maybe you
can do a cheaper functioning evaluation
but get a noisier answer right so this
could be like training on only a
hundredth of your training data and see
how it performed on that or instead of
doing 10-fold cross-validation just
evaluate on one fold and take that
validation error and there's 10 times
faster right but it's going to be a
noisier estimate of the actual test step
performance
so we're actually this hyper band
algorithm is going to come into play
later so so in general model free
methods are flexible because you're
usually randomly sampling from the
configuration space efficient because
you don't have to do any complex logic
to choose which point you're gonna pick
next scalable because a lot of times is
embarrassingly parallel to do these
things but they're not that effective in
other words it takes a lot of model
evaluation or model training function
evaluations to get a good answer right
so this is in contrast to model-based
methods sometimes called Bayesian
optimization where you define a
surrogate model that's approximating the
function from configuration space into
test step performance then you use that
surrogate model to along with something
called an acquisition function to like
pick which configuration you're gonna
try next
so you're explicitly mapping how
configuration space results in test step
performance and then using that model to
say what I'm what you're going to try so
you can have different surrogate models
and different acquisition functions for
different combinations here I think the
first one that became popular was
Gaussian processes which are nice
because they explicitly have uncertainty
built right into them and they're smooth
and nicely behaved the problem with
those were the flexibility part so it is
a little trickier to handle categorical
variables it's very tricky to handle
conditional variables in your search
space one that works better for that was
use a random forest surrogate model and
that results in an algorithm called
shmacked which is also just a cool
algorithm named Bayesian neural networks
I don't know of any implementation out
there I've just heard it mentioned and
referred to another paper so I wouldn't
call it easy because there's nothing to
just go pull and tree structured parson
estimators which is difficult to just
explain on a slide but the idea is that
you're you've got some kernel density
estimates about where your good point
Hyper parameter space and where your bad
points are and you kind of take a ratio
of those to inform where you're gonna
try next and these are really nice
because they are super flexible you have
all the different configuration space
options available and they're also quite
efficient unlike Gaussian processes
which can be like a cubic runtime in the
number of points you've tried so far so
once you get up to
I know trying a thousand different
combinations of hyper parameters your
run time of actually picking where your
next hyper parameter choice you're going
to come from is a thousand cubed and
then your prohibitive TPE I believe is
linear so it's very fast to pick your
next point and then your acquisition
function just how you use your circuit
model to pick your next point will just
go with the expected improvement which
is how likely is that next point to
yield a result better than the best so
far right and then the expected value of
how much better it is than the best so
far so the first thing I'll kind of go
into detail on here is successive
happing and this will feed in the hyper
band in a moment so the idea behind
successive having is you've got some
total budgets so that might be like
training on the entire training set for
a hundred a pox or whatever you think
your training would normally take you
pick some large amount of configurations
and you start them all off at once for a
little while so say in this case you
picked eight configurations and you're
going to run them for an eighth of the
maximum training time and once you've
done them all up to that point you throw
away a certain proportion of them so in
this graph you've throw it away these
top four you're throwing away half and
then you run the ones that survived a
little longer and you get to another
stopping point you throw away the worst
half again and then you run a little
longer
throw away the next half and then the
one that survived kind of all those
tournaments you keep running out to
completion right so you get to try eight
different points and instead of having
eight curves going out to 100% you've
saved yourself a lot of computer
they're right and there's no reason why
you would have to run it until there's
only one remaining you know maybe you
only do two sets of having steps
starting with a and you end up with two
at the end that for final performance
right now the problem with this is that
there's a trade-off here between how
many points you're gonna start with and
how often you're gonna do your cutting
right there's a hyper hyper parameter
hiding here again right and that makes
it not very robust so sometimes it's
good to take a lot of points to start
with and a lot of cuts to whittle them
down sometimes you need to let them run
longer to start to differentiate
themselves or you don't really see which
hyper parameter setting is gonna be the
best until maybe at 50 percent budget or
something lat like that in which case
you'd be better off letting things run
longer before you make your first cut
right so hyper so that's that not robust
part so hyper band solves this by saying
well let's just try all the different
cuts right so I'll try not cutting it
off at all which is equivalent to random
search you're just picking random points
and letting them run to completion oh
and then on the other end there's I'll
pick a whole bunch of points and cutoff
it and then I'll try everything in
between and just allocate my resources
evenly across that which kind of seems
naive but it works really well so I
think that paper came out at the end of
2016 I might have been 2017 and it
showed really good results a because it
tries a lot of things fast and B because
it's very robust to that success of
having problem
however it's not very effective in the
sense that it doesn't always get the
best answer because it's model-free and
it's still randomly sampling
configurations so how can we bring in
that Bayesian optimization and combine
it with it and that's what the paper
Bayesian optimization hyper band did
which came out at ICML 2018 this year so
they start with vanilla hyper band but
they store all the validation scores for
every configuration and budget pair
along the way so remember like on that
first here so they've got these eight
configurations they'll run them out to
this 8th of your budget thing and
they'll store all these values along the
way and then they'll cut these and throw
them away just like in success of having
write or in hyper band remember hyper
band is just doing success of having
with different number of cuts right so
as you store all these config budget
pairs you can start to build up a
Bayesian model about where you should
pick Nicks
you start off randomly sampling but as
the data starts to roll in from trying
all these kind of quick and dirty models
you build up a tree parson estimator to
help you pick where you're gonna try
next once you get enough data you use
your tree parson estimator most of the
time still random sampling once in a
while for robustness ok and as hyper
band continues you'll start to get
things more data on the higher budget
runs which are more accurate validation
scores and you switch over to a new tree
parson estimator at a higher budget and
you keep using the highest budget
available that you have data for and
this turned out to work really well it's
a little bit difficult to see here but
this is from the be OHP paper
boah bees in green here notice the log
scale here for wall clock time ok so
this is this is a 20 x speed-up that's
huge you start getting excellent
performance before they even start
returning their first values here
and you see hyper band and voh beer
almost right on top of each other except
when you get out here hyper band stops
improving much whereas bo HB is starting
to build up this Bayes II and
optimization model and then can
intelligently choose its next points
whereas hyper band keeps randomly
sampling so you random clean sample at
first with quick and dirty models you
start building up your busy and stuff
and then you can end up with a 55 times
speed-up over regular random search so
55 times speed up on your hyper
parameter search isn't a reason to look
at this library then I don't know what
is so that library that this is
implemented in is called HP band ster
hyper band on steroids it's very well
architected it's from that same lab in
Germany the auto ml group at Freiburg it
just started in 2018 because that's when
the paper was published but it looks
like it's gonna be very well maintained
so far has had a lot of releases and
updates and they're very responsive to
github issues and they've got very nice
documentation along with examples so
it's super easy to learn okay very
flexible configuration space definition
I'm going to show you that in a second
to give you an idea what that looks like
and as far as the architecture goes you
can run it across multiple nodes right
so you kind of have one nodes your
master the brains is doing the
configuration selection so it's it's
building up that tree parts an estimator
in deciding what configuration to try
next and then you can have a whole bunch
of worker nodes all operating
independently running in parallel that
are taking a configuration and a budget
and training the model on that
configuration out to that budget and
then this is all orchestrated with some
name name servers and dispatchers stuff
to get that a multi node capability but
this could easily run on one machine
across different cores as well right
so this is what a configuration for
hydroids comp net might look like so you
could say I've got a learning rate I
specify a lower bound and an upper bound
a starting value and that is a log
transformed so that you're equally as
likely to step ten times higher ten
times lower instead of just ignoring the
low end range if you didn't do that log
transform you've got categorical hyper
parameters so you can choose between a
demand SGD in this case we've got a
momentum term that your uniform
distribution over however you're only
going to use the momentum term if your
optimizers SGD so that's a condition
there right so that's a conditional
hyper parameter thanks because Adam
apparently they're just going to use the
default you've got integer values
integer values that are logged space for
number of filters and then you can have
greater than conditions as well so
before we had a boolean condition
basically here we're saying if you've
got more than one convolution layer you
need to specify the number of filters in
the second layer if you've got more than
two convolution layers you need to
specify the number of filters and the
third layer yeah okay
and then this is just I've showed you
one algorithm when one library there's
actually quite a few out there I would
suggest you start with HP banister but
hyper opt has been around the longest
that's from about 2011 and the original
TP ePaper spearmint is Gaussian
processes smack I mentioned earlier uses
random forced circuit models sk opt I
believe is Gaussian processes to but
smack and sk opt i think are actually
pretty well maintained as well smack
might be at the same lab now in freiburg
they might have taken it over there's a
commercial company called cig opt where
one of the kind of earlier year people
making a lot of headway on bayesian
optimizations went started to start up
where they have an api where you don't
have to submit your data or anything you
basically tell them these are my hyper
parameters and they'll tell you which
ones to try you train your model tell
them the result they'll tell you the
next one to try right so and that's all
in api gateway and then if you're
interested in like the full auto ml data
pipeline thing that i kind of mentioned
at the beginning here's some more
libraries to check out i just heard an
interview with the guy that wrote teapot
on the dataframe podcast that was very
good
looks very interesting and then some
references and suggested reading if
you're interested in this this book is
freely available online right now in
draft form and i'd highly recommend it
if you're interested in oto mo and i've
got a few more minutes I guess I've got
like 10 seconds let me just say I kept
kind of referring to deep learning in
terms of the early stop anything and
like how many training did how much
training data you used you could do the
same thing with validation folds on
something like gradient boosting
machines as well or if you've got small
data you could use the number of
validation fold says you're kind of
budget whether you're gonna go from one
full of the ten fold sits on so it's
really widely applicable that
multi-resolution thing
and that's any questions
thanks for the talk have you seen any
examples of people using this on like
collections of data sets because I don't
know it just would be interesting to see
yes the papers themselves you know like
to compare different hpo methods on
various benchmark data sets and I know
that he kind of full on auto ml stuff
the guy that made teapot his name is
escaping me was saying that people are
have been throwing it at problems and
getting like top 10% on Kaggle just out
of the box and it's surprising a lot of
people so it's these things work pretty
well you some of that I think the auto
ml thing so you can get like one of the
papers talks about Frankenstein stacking
models so just very descriptive in terms
of what you end up getting out of them
because you think of neural networks are
trying no networks daqing all these
other crazy models with genetic
programming for your feature engineering
right
any more questions
all right thanks dad yep
[Applause]